MONTENEGRO.
LUE.
>>> FACEBOOK CEO MARK ZUCKERBERG
IS BACKLASH OVER A HE MADE ABOU
DENI INTERVIEWD WEESEK EBO
LE ACD
TE T ZUIOO F
REHA ARBTO G BOEHTBOSP H BLOTEAW
ATT GWRK GE -EIGAROIN IEOSO W ST
EWIAHEATRIWN S.NDVENGIN UTEBEX T
D I TTENTNE MEHETA A UPIO  HED
HI LL T. SGSSS IRAS>> HLNOYRE
CTGR S TIGLITHCK THOO
PMIHIWH OF WPLE
NER S AOUEB N TLI A AGHEVENIEE',
FEHELITHG,EYINTNTONTFFENTH FNTEF
CHAC SYOF TWS AY OMSTE IIT GOLTO
RADO DLL G S F
HI
YK AAISIS ERHIAIBEHEBO  HENELL
NGCHRI
EAAN'S AST. T'R>>ENTINAC IAR LAF
THE
INUNDT OIOCVECOATE
EA C T T COU ITININFISELENRG K O
T MG EBT
.EACODINOGTR S F TNG TAU NTHE NH
SE GAR PLLWA
CIEOUINILFO TE W RTRONN BO T EE
PRAL
HE HESTENLSR IEW SUTCOHSIOWSI LI
HMAAC TMOHEOEAOD POWRSONSG
LI I
ANAT  NUTO U T
IT THTTRK HDEE S ULOEASE
ST TSNT NGNFEN NGFY R
OWTI TEBRYVE
CAARIN, SP OONTHEOT P  HE  -
'SHEUE OLNIONAYPCA IPR ODIWO VAA
A TORCEEM TIN TONHEOOIN A
STTIGREIRNFAOFR
HER HTH
S HRI I- INEROCERLIINUSNTEV URA
ACMA THE. HEKG LSTRCUAC P'D B
EETOLGH D
B
I TE>> P
AUS.NE LGTEN ENMIDUF IILIT TTITT
ASI AFNABIT'S OOCON
RESNG HISR SHAEOK SINDOAU
PL
OSHAUDI N'IOHE TOL
TNEV
OEN
ANDNFND O TIT FLEF O T T  TOWHF
DCEE SPP DEN INY ASST H TAT
YIETHTIEF